you've already announced that there's
going to be a 7 billion pound for
new transport projects outside london
can you confirm that just one and a half
billion of that money hasn't been
announced previously
so the transport money that we announced
is a combination of two things one we
previously announced an overall envelope
to improve how people get around our big
cities we wanted our cities whether
that's in the west midlands or in the in
t side or greater manchester to have the
same type of transport settlements that
london's always enjoyed where locally
elected mayors can take a pot of money
and decide how best to spend it to help
all their residents and we previously
announced 4.2 billion pounds for that
what we've actually done is top that up
as you said by a billion and a half
pounds but then crucially give out the
allocations for in that envelope where
are all the bits gonna go so it's gonna
create trams over here bus links over
here road improvements over there so
whether you're in west yorkshire west
midlands greater manchester t-side local
residents are going to see improvements
over the next few years as their leaders
are given the same type of power and
funding that london has always enjoyed
so it's a great example of leveling up
in practice and it's ultimately just
going to create growth in all of these
places okay so that's a billion and a
half's worth of leveling up um we're
going to talk to tracy breben a bit
later the mayor of uh
west yorkshire
can you assure her that the money that
she's going to get 830 million i think
uh will
uh
fund a new stop in bradford
uh
from the new northern powerhouse rail
line plus an hs2 extension uh to leads
so more broadly and you'll speak to
tracy later and we had comments i think
yesterday whether it's from andy burnham
or indeed andy street in the west
midlands our local mayor's actually all
warmly welcoming i think the funding
that was announced everybody likes money
but let's see what it's going to be i
think your specific question actually
relates to something different so what
the money announced yesterday was about
is about what we call inter-city
transportation that's about how do we
get people who live in and around a city
to be able to get into the middle of it
and out again easily we actually don't
do as well as we should do on that if
you look at cities like say marseille or
lyon in france it it takes virtually no
time at all within half an hour for
people to get from the out to the inn
that that journey time in some of our
cities outside of london can take twice
as long and that's not great it's not
great for creating jobs not great for
people's quality of life that's what
we're trying to fix with these
settlements that we've announced what
you're talking about is something
different and that's about how we
connect up our towns and cities to each
other now that's going to be part of
something called the integrated rail
plan and plans for that will be
announced shortly but we have committed
to improving the links between all our
great cities across the north for
example between
liverpool manchester and leeds uh
bradford will will obviously be a part
of that as well yeah dan jarvis who uh
is the mayor in uh elsewhere in
yorkshire was saying yesterday that he's
looking forward to some money for the
extension of hs2 and tracy braven is
quite specific
whether it's this package of money this
weekend or what or the three year pack
spending review she wants a stop in
bradford and she wants hs2 to go delete
is that going to happen so that will be
part of the integrated rail plan which
will spell out our plans to connect up
all our towns and cities not just across
the north but also across the midlands
it wouldn't be right for me to to
speculate on that now but what i can
tell you is people will see enormous
improvements in journey times as we
deliver what the prime minister said
when he was first elected an
infrastructure revolution in this
country but and why is this important
because all very well to talk about the
money we're spending it's important
because it creates jobs it creates
prosperity if we can better connect up
our towns and cities that's going to
allow our economy to grow it's going to
increase productivity and allow people
to access better paying jobs you know
that's how we build a stronger economy
in this country and that's what next
week's budget is all about it's about
building that stronger economy for the
british people okay we have to have
people who can do the jobs and you put
some money into skills and education
let's start
let's start at the very beginning you
are
going to give 500 million years for
early years education now your
conservative predecessors cut the shore
start program by uh about 1.2 billion
pounds over the past decade um
is this 500 million an admission that
that was just a mistake
so what the this money is about is
actually addressing something probably
slight slightly different and there's
been enormous work being done and
predicted by one of my colleagues andrea
ledson and also fiona bruce and what
they've that what they've showed very
clearly as the evidence does that the
the very early years in young families
lives are critical and that's where
parents often struggle and that's where
actually we need to provide a little bit
more attention so what we're announcing
is funding to create a network of family
hubs which are broader than shaw start
centers and they bring together lots of
different services for new parents and
for the first time we're going to roll
those out and whether that's parenting
program support for for mental health
help with very very young children with
things like numeracy and literacy as
well all those types of things we can
bring together help young parents at a
difficult time we know that that will
make an enormous difference to those
parents and those young families lives
so i'm delighted that we're able
werewolves to do this and it's based on
a lot of evidence and research that's
been carried out over the last few years
which demonstrates this is an important
thing to do well your predecessor george
osborne who's really principally
responsible for taking a little bit more
than a billion pounds out of short start
i mean he's out of politics now so you
can say that was a mistake can't you no
i think it's right to judge everyone by
the context that they are doing their
jobs in and one thing that my
predecessors not just george did was
ensure that i actually had a very strong
economy and strong set of public
finances that i inherited now that was
really important because then when
coronavirus came which nobody knew about
i was able to respond in a comprehensive
and generous fashion to support families
businesses in the country through the
crisis and actually part of my
responsibility
it's an error
no way you can pick on individual things
but overall what my predecessors did was
deliver a strong economy and a strong
set of public finances which we have now
benefited from over the past year as
we've responded and protected and
supported people now part of my job and
part of what next week's budget is about
is doing that again it's delivering that
stronger economy that stronger set of
public finances because whenever the
next difficult thing comes along i want
to make sure whoever's sitting in this
chair can do what i did over the last
year and that's the right thing for the
country it's the right thing for the
british people to have that stronger
economy to fall back on well let's keep
talking about the spending because it's
quite a lot of it you're announcing a
skills package worth three billion
pounds now a lot of this just replaces
funds we would have got from the eu
structural funds anyway
but
where exactly is the new money in that
three billion pound package
so what you'll see all the details of
this laid out this week now there are
we've talked a lot about building a
high-wage economy now the best way to do
that is to give people opportunities to
retrain to upskill at any stage in their
lives and then get really well-paid jobs
as a result of that and we've got a
suite of interventions to do that the
prime minister's lifetime skills
guarantee is one i could pick on as an
example we have around 10 million adults
in this country who sadly don't have the
equivalent of a level three
qualification and an a-level equivalent
qualification now for the first time
the government will pay for those people
to get that qualification that's worth
almost 3 000 pounds a year in cost but
we know if we do that those people are
much more likely to get a job and earn
more money so that's one of the most
important and powerful things we can do
to help people earn more create a better
life for them and their families that's
why skills are important and it's all
part of building that stronger economy
that i talked about and that's what
you'll see next week one of the biggest
issues in building a strong economy is
productivity now um
here's the problem
pretty much every year we look at this
whoever's chancellor trump it's some
huge sum for skills training
to increase productivity
the ifs estimates that over the past 10
years we spent
39.5 billion pounds into adult training
uh and skills
and here's what happened as a result i
wanted to show you this uh to the effect
on productivity
i'm going to show you a graph uh which
says shows the increase in productivity
over the last decade uh the in the
increase in productivity is as near zero
as dammit
until you've deci worked out why that
money isn't making any difference aren't
we just throwing good money after bed
no there's lots of different things that
go into increasing our productivity our
plan for growth that we've set out
involves investing in infrastructure
innovation and skills i think of it like
that so infrastructure we've talked a
little bit about actually earlier on in
the program that's going to help drive
up our productivity not to get technical
about it there's something called
agglomeration economics making sure that
our cities can perform at their highest
potential so those investments will help
us do that we know that they would trust
all the clever people and all the
productive people in one place you get
no it's not so much about the clever
people for a given city for it to
maximize its potential we need to make
it easy for people to move around it so
that's what those investments will do
and we know that economically that will
make a difference so that's the
infrastructure piece for example skills
we've just talked about and giving
people the tools they need to get better
jobs and we've got a range of things
that we're doing there that we haven't
done before actually the prime
minister's lifetime skills guarantee is
new things like skills boot camps are
new in this country working with
hundreds of employers to design three to
four month courses with a job interview
at the end with proper employer
engagement during the training these are
new interventions and we think they're
going to make a big difference and then
the last piece is innovation is how do
we build a high innovation economy
that's going to be ready to embrace some
of the technological change we're seeing
so there it's investing in r d it's
making sure our growing companies can
get the capital they need it's about
making sure we attract talented people
from abroad it's about helping our
companies grow so our help to grow
program again we've never done something
like this before it's giving small and
medium-sized companies mini mbas support
with digital technology i'm confident
that all of those things are going to
raise their productivity and that chart
that we saw will will start to tick up
but chanter
is there a big elephant in the room here
i mean
you're saying all of this and you're
offering the money and so on
is one of the reasons that nothing
changes is that in spite of all this
money for training
fi the apprenticeship levy huge 2.7
billion i think uh
5 000 employers don't use it 400 million
worth of that levy
expired we understand last year and
isn't the problem really the one that
the prime minister and also your
colleague the home secretary frequently
talk about which is that as long as
employers can bring in cheap
labor through immigration they aren't
going to invest in training and skills
and raise productivity in the way that
you want it to be raised
well i wouldn't say that nothing has
changed and actually i think some of the
things that we've already put in place
are starting to yield benefits
that that graph is over the last 10
years but let me just look at the time
that i've had this job and what we're
seeing now what we're seeing is record
numbers of job vacancies we're seeing
employers wanting to hire we're seeing
businesses intentions to invest growing
again partly aided by measures that
we've taken like the super deduction
which is a huge tax incentive for
businesses to invest in increasing their
productivity and we're seeing people's
wages rise uh real wages today are three
and a half percent higher than they were
before the crisis so actually all the
things that we put in place the plan for
jobs that i've been on this show talking
about a lot over the last year and a
half that plan for jobs is working
people are seeing the benefits of it and
i'm confident that if we continue to
deliver on investing and infrastructure
innovation our skills we will see our
growth rise and next week's budget will
demonstrate that plan in action we will
build that stronger economy we'll drive
up our economic growth and productivity
and people are going to feel that in
higher living standards and a better
quality of life all right let's let's
talk about what some of your colleagues
in the conservative party say which is
that you're not really a very
conservative chancellor at all um
you said in
the uh the prime minister said in your
pa in the party conference that um you
would be first government in decades not
to dock these hard decisions you'd be
radical and optimistic let's see if
that's actually true
for example nobody wants to keep the
system of business rates
you said in your 2019 uh
manifesto that we will cut the burden of
tax on business by reducing business
rates and you promised a fundamental
review two years now are you going to be
telling us on wednesday that you're
going to get rid of business right well
i will talk on on wednesday about the
conclusion of that fundamental review so
it wouldn't be appropriate for me to do
that it's actually concluded so yes we
will get an outcome from this we'll get
an outcome from the review we've said
that we would conclude the review in the
autumn and you'll see that i mean but on
business rates it's important to
remember this is a government that's put
in place the small business rates
reduction which means a third of all
properties don't pay any business rates
at all any more and over the past year
and a half through chronovirus we've
delivered about 16 billion pounds worth
of tax cuts on business rates to help
hospitality and retail businesses get
through all of this and
in terms of the review and
i think you've got the shadow chancellor
on uh later on in the show i mean there
are people who say you should just
abolish business rates which i think is
what the labour party position is
business rates obviously
yeah business rates obviously does raise
25 billion pounds i'm sure you'll be
asking her well what is a system that
would replace that if you are going to
just stand up and say you're going to
abolish it that's okay i'll do that and
so what about your your as i said we've
delivered short-term relief during the
last 18 months through chronovirus that
support extends through to next year
we'll be talking a little bit more about
the future and some things that we can
do in business rates next week in the
budget but that's all part of a budget
that as i said it builds a stronger
economy and you will see us supporting
business and there are lots of different
ways to support business business rates
is one of them incentives to invest like
our super deduction the biggest ever tax
cut for businesses that this country has
seen and that's creating a strong
climate for investment and that's going
to create jobs as well helping small
companies with mini mbas digital skills
help to grow i mentioned helping them
take on new staff young people through
the kickstart scheme a lot of different
things we're doing to help business
but you understand where where i'm going
here because it's reported that this
week
the former prime minister david cameron
told uh mr johnson that at least in my
day we cut taxes you are not doing that
at all you're presiding over the highest
tax burden since post-war period and we
can
have another look at this the ifs says
that
you've got a sustained level of public
spending 42 of gdp
and it's the highest since 1985 and
actually look at the graph since oh
the post-war period 1950.
you're still
pretty high 35
that's not the low tax conservatism that
the prime minister promised and you
yourself said you stand for
yes and of course i do stand for that
and that's what i would want to deliver
and that's where my instincts are but
you also have to take a step back trevor
and think well what have i and the
government had to grapple with over the
past year year and a half we've had
the biggest economic shock that we've
experienced in 300 years
we've had the need rightly to come and
support the country through that which
has obviously been enormously costly it
drove our borrowing up to levels we
haven't seen since world war ii just on
the other side of that
chart uh and we've got a strong ambition
to invest in public services and drive
up our growth by investing in
infrastructure innovation and skills all
the things that we've talked about
earlier so those are the things i'm
grappling with and i and i've got to
take the world as it comes you know i
wish i hadn't had to deal with
coronavirus in a once in 300 year
economic shock and all the damage that
has done to our economy uh and an nhs
backlog that was stretching into the
millions that we thought it was really
important rightly to get some funding in
to address
so but those are the challenges that i'm
grappling with and i have to take those
challenges and figure out what's the
right way to do that and we've made some
decisions which i believe although they
are difficult are the right decisions
they're the responsible decisions and
ultimately will deliver on the things
that people want to see us deliver on
and indeed build that strong economy for
the future which is going to drive
growth and raise our living standards
to sum up what johnson-ism
in the economic terms right now looks
like is tight fist can fiscal control
squeeze on every department except maybe
health
lots of universal credit 20 up 20 pounds
uplift prospect of inflation at 4
percent
and by the way
more on less on public services when
there's more demand less in wage packets
when uh prices are going up now
offer some of your colleagues at least
some hope that that isn't the totality
of johnsonism and that there might be
some tax cuts
well what i tell you is this our focus
over the last year year and a half has
been on delivering our plan for jobs i'm
pleased to say that plan has worked with
far fewer people unemployed than we
feared the economy recovering faster
than people thought so that's good news
that plan for jobs has worked and
looking forward next week's budget is
about the future it's about building
that stronger economy for our country
you've asked what does that mean well it
means a few things it actually means
very strong continued investment in
public services it means driving our
future economic growth by investing in
infrastructure innovation and skills the
things we've talked about it means
giving businesses confidence through all
the things we're going to do to support
them and lastly it means supporting
working families as we have done through
the last year there lots of different
ways to support working families but
those things combined are what deliver a
stronger economy for the british people
and that's what next week's budget is
going to do okay give your colleagues
somehow rule out tax rises before the
next election yeah trevor you you're
asking me to do my budget live on your
show which although it would be great
well because i would do it in parliament
on wednesday all right um one last
question we have cop 26 next week
one thing we know is no presidency
no president putin
no new restrictions on fossil fuels if
the australians and the chinese and to
some extent the saudis though they're
making a gesture uh say uh would would
uh have have it
um
it's a bit of a shambles isn't it no i
think that's
not right at all if you look at when we
first took on the presidency of cop i
think about 30 of the global economy had
climate targets in place thanks in part
to the great work of the prime minister
and the cop president alex sharma that
number has now gone up to 80
because there's a team of people
demonstrating uk leadership on the world
stage to try and get more people to sign
up to target so i think that's actually
a great success story before we've even
got to the summit in glasgow and you
know what you're going to see
particularly on on the bit that i'm
responsible for for example the finance
side of it i'm hosting a full day on
wednesday we're having great turnout
from finance ministers and financial
companies from around the world
committed to transforming our financial
system to make it
fit for the future to help with the
transition and there's great news there
if you look at london just this week the
uk has been named best place in the
world for green finance we issued our
second sovereign green bond which now
makes us the largest uh those are the
third largest issuer of sovereign green
bonds anywhere in the world and we've
only been going a month so you know
actually there's there's lots there's
lots to celebrate and actually i think
will be a big success